we make way for the star of around the
horn Tim kalma Shawn down this morning
news columnist as we delve a little
deeper into Mark Cuban and a couple of
stories here which one do you want to
start with Tim thank you both so
glorious you want to start let's start
with the smaller one the $600,000 fine I
think that's the minor story at this
point is he too honest here he got fine
for being too honest yeah I mean you
know rick carlisle has been asked a lot
by me and others about what's going on
and he tries to talk about some of the
young lineups they play in the fourth
quarter sort of a euphemism for the best
players or sometimes on the bench and
human just said what they're doing but i
mean he still shouldn't say it it's just
you can't you can't go out and tell
people who are season ticket holders or
trying to watch on TV that we're trying
to lose games and that you know that
just doesn't fly so i'm not surprised he
got fine but he was being honest but he
said even worse a year ago on our show
when he said we're doing everything we
can to lose games I mean no yeah but
what he said here so is once we were
eliminated so you can kind of tolerate
that it's a just think is at the start
of last season when there were three and
thirteen he sculpted all of it and
laughed at the media who talked about
tanking and said you never do that you'd
ever want to teach young players bad
habits that's how you get to be four
years away from four years away then he
went on year so and and and you know
made big news by saying once we were
eliminated we did everything we can to
lose games you can kind of justify that
but I mean no one's eliminated in the
middle of the season and they've been
doing this for a long time so he's just
being look everybody knows Philadelphia
did it but the owner and Sam hinkie
didn't come out and say it
Kuban came out and said it so he got
fined did you see that the Chicago Bulls
on the same day yesterday that Cuban
gets popped for 600 grand
the Bulls say they're gonna go with
their younger players the final 25 games
so there basically
doing where's Allison right now there's
a team is doing it Atlanta I mean
Atlanta Chicago traded Barrett suits
because he was playing - well James ear
no I'm serious yeah Atlanta Sacramento I
mean Sacramento has no business playing
as poorly as they do is so they owned
the rising stars challenge but they're
still gonna lose as many games as they
can it's now they think they've changed
this with the lottery next year but you
know everybody's chances go to the go
down to 14% but we'll say what's the
local reaction to the Sports Illustrated
report about the sexual harassment
charges that had been going on for over
20 years it's you know kind of amazement
that it's been going on this long and
when I first read it Tuesday not
starting to read it too late Tuesday
night when it came on or saw it I
thought tardy mastery and buddy - I know
I've written something about this what
did I write and I being the internet
savvy person I am I called somebody at
work to tell him to send it to me so I
couldn't look it up myself and it was 20
years ago is in August of 1998 Ross
Perot still on the team and the
Mavericks investigated turdy Missouri
for six weeks and they wouldn't say what
the investigations are for the same
thing sexual misconduct or harassment in
the workplace and they hired this guy
buddy Pitman to run their HR and that's
all that you ever said about it and
that's all and Mark Steyn was at our
paper he wrote the story I wrote a
column about it and that was really all
it was ever said about it and turdy mo
was a guy who was here for I think 14
years under Kuban and you never he
wasn't a very yummy everybody sent a low
to him but he wasn't the guy you quoted
so nobody really knew what was going on
he never came up again so you kind of
figured it it went away the idea that
all these stories these women told John
Wertheim and Jessica Luthor that going
on in 2004 and 2007 and all these things
it's just incredible to think that Mark
Cuban who run and micro manages
everything didn't know any of this
never
heard about it you know his HR director
didn't tell him so he had no way of
knowing I mean that's people find that
part of it just preposterous and that's
going to be his hardest thing to sell is
that a guy who is always bragged about
being an owner who his hands on and
knows everything and talks to people and
he's transparent all the rest he was
clueless as to what was going on in his
own business office is there a chance
with the severity of these charges that
Kuban could lose his team I would say at
this very early stage no just as Donald
sterling this stuff was different and
that was directly him and this is going
to be more at the worst I think you're
gonna reach the conclusion Cuban
probably knew but didn't do anything
about it which is bad so I'm and these
stories I mean we've seen what's
happened you know all over Hollywood and
sports and politics and everywhere else
so I can't say it won't but I think this
is different if it's if it's if it's not
directly tying it to him it's more his
responsibility than something he did but
I obviously day and I wouldn't rule it
out I mean these things get legs and
they grow and and you can't stop them
here's the here's one of those puzzling
parts of this that you have the mavs
dot-com reporter Earl Snead who was
still employed after two separate
domestic violence incidents and then
he's he can't go into Canada
to follow a company the team I get mark
has to know that and you still employ
this guy yeah that's that's the rough
part of the story too you could you
could argue the second chance idea that
would get a lot of people and that's
fine but Martin knew about the second
time he had an incident and that was
when two Mavericks employ yeah yeah it
was dating so then he draws up or he has
an HR guy drop a contract you cannot
have one-on-one conversations or contact
with females in the Mavericks
organization well their PR person is
Sarah Melton you know didn't role was
never able to talk to Sarah
the last four years I mean that's just a
silly thing and Cubans you know the only
thing Cuban has spoken about Tim McMahon
was was the Earl Snead stuff and he was
very apologetic about it but he also
comes across sounding ridiculous when he
says we were worried that if we fired
him he'd just get hired somewhere else
and go do it there I mean that's that's
a terrible way of thinking Jim Campbell
Shaw around the horn Dallas Morning News
columnist I'm trying to figure out this
Kawhi Leonard situation I know you're in
Dallas but with with the Spurs and it
feels like you know they get the right
players with the right personalities
that fit that team what what has
happened what's gone wrong here I don't
know I mean that whole thing that is
gone was you know there's obviously he
has been at odds for a while with the
team's medical people and you know this
person had this very very I mean they
deserved it but they that's very
fortunate run when your best player is
over two decades there David Robinson
Tim Duncan Ginobili Parker I mean guys
who love that team and do everything
they can for your occasionally gonna run
you know enter the real world and have
some problems and now they have an issue
and I don't you know nobody really seems
to know if if Kawhi I thought he was
rushed back too soon or if they thought
he was taking too long you know just
what it is but it's like they've given
up now Wow we don't expect to see them
the rest of year yeah well they can't
take the records do good so you can't go
anywhere I mean there's no there's
nothing for them to gain from this by
sitting him so it's it's kind of
Popovich his first time he's ever had a
problem like this any cowboy drama we
need to be aware Dan we've got the draft
coming to town April 26 I hope you'll be
riding in with your show we'd love to
have you I think you're familiar with
McKinney Avenue yeah I've been there
make you are yeah I've been there before
I watch you are
that was the old team Calvin show yeah
the fun one yeah you know diet cokes
yeah I mean the Cowboys about uh they're
gonna have to have a very interesting
offseason they got a lot of things to
fix there's still a good team but they
need receivers they need defense they
didn't do anything with the coaches up
high they hired a bunch of different
assistants but Jerry is gonna want to
make some noise from the draft is here I
don't know what that will be but well
you what do you make of this Michael
Irvin yelling at me at the at the
Superbowl about you know des I don't
know about that what did he yell at you
for my said should they move on from Dez
Bryant and then he oh oh that's right
yeah yes verbally spanked me on you know
why would his des Brian gonna be there
with that team it's a good question dan
I've wrote that I didn't think he would
and I I still lean that way and because
they did this with DeMarcus we're not
saying that worked really well DeMarcus
or won a Super Bowl at Denver but yeah I
don't know that he would have you know
the only thing we're here with this team
I think that might be whether they have
there already I think they're 19 million
under the cap which sounds like a lot
but they gotta say Mike Martin they got
a franchise DeMarcus Lauren so you got
to do a lot of stuff if they want to
really redo things and really try to
change some things around here I think
they might have to move on from it
so I still like it's a chance 40% chance
42 42 percent chance yes all right are
you when around the horns tonight I am
thank you for asking uh
tough loss yesterday yeah yeah I don't
get over those losses on around the horn
like when you lose I lose well here's
the we all do Dan and the hard thing is
you know going day to get back-to-back
days coming back from a loss I haven't
really had time to digest that one and
now I've got to go against woody and
Ramona shell
Ramona Shelburne and clean the eights I
mean this is there's a whole new crew
from the team that the group was it
brought me down yesterday
why don't you tank this just in
so you've had writers who wanted to get
out of the show early perhaps and they
tanked on a round the horn is that what
you're saying Tim Keller Sean I'm just
saying I might have called myself out a
few times for past mistakes and that
results in a deduction and I needed to
go to lunch or Tony really on the show
this is huge news yeah this is big news
right Wow I hope this is brought up by
reali later today don't you guys have a
conference call or something we'll be
rooting for you Tim is only we can't
leave all right thank you cowboy show
ESPN around the horn Dallas Morning News
columnist I know he joked about you know
being the the former Tim Couch show Tim
had a good time but you know Tim sought
help and he's a different person and you
know he's doing doing well good dude
tanking on around the horn who would
have thought we broke that yes we did
yeah somebody's gonna confirm it John
Clayton might confirm that but we broke
that story